Abby finds a family and Dan Fielding
finally achieves his dream. But what
will Season 2 of the new "Night Court"
bring us? Let's lay out the evidence.
Abby Stone, of course, does not end up as the
Manhattan night court judge by accident. Her
father was the affable, magic-loving judge
Harry Stone. The late Harry Anderson played
him for nine seasons on the original "Night
Court." By taking over her father's old bench
and recruiting his former colleague, Dan Fielding,
to serve as public defender, she hopes to learn
more about that time in her father's life. And
perhaps she'll learn more about herself as well.
As the series begins, Abby is in the midst of
a prolonged engagement with her long-distance
boyfriend, Rand. It's clear from the start that
something is out of step between them, and when
Rand finally makes the trip from their upstate
New York small town to visit her in the big city,
it's even more apparent that they no longer fit
into each other's lives. At first, he is her rock,
providing necessary comfort as she struggles to
fit into her uncertain new position. But by the
end of the season, Abby has made the bench her
own and won over her cynical colleagues with
gumption and good cheer. Suddenly, it's
her future with Rand that is uncertain.
"The Honorable Dan Fielding," the two-part season
finale, puts its characters at personal and
professional crossroads. As the title suggests,
Dan has been offered a judgeship back home in
Louisiana, which Abby responds to in her typically
anxious and overexcited fashion. She plans a
massive going-away party that she hopes will also
function as a "don't actually go away" party,
while trying to ignore the fact that Rand
feels neglected. The pressure is too much,
and Abby acts out recklessly. An attempt to aid
an elderly defendant, Louise, lands her in jail
and facing a trumped-up felony charge thanks
to weaselly District Attorney Jeff Dewitt.
With Dan as her attorney, Abby faces the
possibility of disbarment and perhaps even
jail time for trying to help a little old lady
break into her boyfriend's nursing home. Dan
pleads with her to let him foist the blame on
Louise, but Abby refuses to let someone else
suffer for her actions. In the end, she's saved
by a slew of character witnesses who testify to
her sterling character — well, that and the fact
that Dewitt coerced Louise into wearing a wire.
The judge declares a mistrial, and Abby returns
to the bench. Rand heads home to upstate New York
after he and Abby finally come to terms with the
fact that they have grown apart. Dan, meanwhile,
says his goodbyes to Abby and to Night Court, and
he takes his seat on the bench in rural Louisiana.
"I'm not being selfish. This is what I've
always wanted. I'm not abandoning her."
There's a "lost in time" aspect to the "Night
Court" revival. The sets all look pretty much the
same as they did in the 1980s and the cases called
before the court are not much different. Everyone
has smart phones, but they rarely figure into the
plot, and the titular tech investment opportunity
in the episode "Past Apps" is merely the catalyst
for Abby's ethical quandary in dealing with an
old fashioned con man. This is all very much by
design; when developing the series, producer Dan
Rubin and production designer Glenda Rovello
raided the Warner Bros. television archives,
grabbing surviving set decorations from
the original series and even using the
blueprints for the original courtroom set
to make sure the new one was to scale.
The series' nostalgic bona fides don't stop at
the set design, though. The revival is steeped
in the same vaudeville energy that made
the original series a little old fashioned,
even for the '80s. The show's insistence
on warm-and-fuzzy comedy that recalls a
more comforting era was very much a selling
point for star Melissa Rauch. She told Uproxx,
"I sort of liken it to a bit of a time machine
that can take you back to that happiness."
As a result, the show largely steers
clear of any divisive real-world issues
regarding the criminal justice system;
the fact that the courtroom has barely
been renovated in four decades is
arguably its sharpest political gag.
Dan's move to Louisiana is a homecoming in
more ways than one. Actor John Larroquette,
who won four Emmys in a row for his portrayal of
Dan on the original series, is from New Orleans
and has kept close ties to his hometown since
leaving for Hollywood in the 1970s. In 2013,
he was even awarded an honorary doctorate from
the University of New Orleans. Larroquette and
his character share a Louisiana upbringing thanks
to the original "Night Court" writers, who over
the years mined a lot of humor from the idea that
Dan, the erudite Manhattan attorney constantly
trying to climb the social ladder, was born on the
bayou and raised in the possum-filled backwoods.
The revival keeps Dan's Pelican State birthright,
but takes it easy on the redneck jokes;
it also keeps Dan's womanizing past in
the past. During the '80s, Dan was one
of network TV's most shameless lotharios, and
his constant pursuit of every woman in sight
was one of the original series' most reliable
wells of humor. The episode that was planned
to be the series finale features a nightmare
sequence in which Dan is tried, convicted,
and hanged by a courtroom filled with every woman
he had ever slept with. Three decades on, however,
Dan is a changed man; when Abby knocks on his
door in the pilot episode he's a grieving widower,
the kind of man who can no longer see himself
being with any woman, much less every woman.
That first scene between Larroquette and
Rauch in the pilot episode is heavy with
grief — almost too heavy, but that's a burden
that "Night Court" has had to carry from nearly
the beginning. The show's early seasons were
marked by the deaths of actresses Selma Diamond
in 1985 and her replacement Florence Halop
just a year later. Abby's grief over her
father and connection to Dan as a surrogate
forms the emotional backbone of the revival,
given extra poignance by the real-life
death of star Harry Anderson in 2018.
The show mourns not just a beloved
character, but a beloved actor as well.
For as much weight as Anderson's death is
given on the show, however, other recent
cast deaths are not mentioned at all. 2021
saw the deaths of both Charles Robinson,
who played longtime officer of the court Mac,
and Markie Post, who joined the show as public
defender Christine Sullivan in Season 3. It's
possible that their characters' absence will be
commemorated in Season 2, but it's possible
that in the world of "Night Court," Mac and
Christine are still alive. The 1992 finale saw
Christine leaving the public defenders' office
for a nascent political career, while
Mac tendered his resignation in order
to fulfill his dream of becoming a film director.
It could very well be that Christine and Mac are
simply too busy in Washington and Hollywood,
respectively, to show up to court anymore.
The untimely deaths of Anderson, Robinson,
and Post cast a pall over the revival series.
After all, half the fun of legacy sequels
like this is to bring back the old cast for
one last hurrah. Other than Larroquette,
there's hardly any original cast left,
but the show kept one trick up its sleeve. In
the final moments of the finale, Dan takes yet
another case of a soon-to-be bride arrested
for fighting in the French Quarter during her
bachelorette party. But when he looks up at
the defendant, he sees a very familiar face:
"Fielding? They made you a
judge? Take me back to jail."
Yes, it's former night court bailiff Roz
Russell, played by comedian Marsha Warfield.
Warfield joined the cast of the original
series in 1986 after Florence Halop died
earlier that year. The wisecracking
Roz was quickly a fan favorite,
and her verbal sparring with Dan often cut the
egotistical lawyer down to size. In an interview
with "Variety" published after the season finale
aired, Warfield spoke to the bittersweet feeling
of being back on that set after so many years,
and without so many of her colleagues. Overall,
though, Warfield was happy to be reunited
with Larroquette and to meet the new
generation — especially Lacretta, the new bailiff
in town. Warfield said of their conversation,
"I told her, 'just do you, baby. Just be
you and enjoy it and enjoy the ride.'"
"Welcome to Night Court."
The last two scenes of the finale represent
a new status quo for the series. Abby,
newly separated from Rand and exonerated
on her felony charge, returns to the bench
reinvigorated and ready to hear the first of
two hot dog-related cases. Dan, meanwhile,
has achieved a long time career goal and has
become a judge himself, presiding over case
after case of drunken New Orleans brawls. If
Larroquette remains a regular on the show,
it seems unlikely that his Louisiana interlude
will last very long into Season 2. However,
it's possible that sending Dan off to his dream
job is the show's way of bidding farewell to
the character, with Larroquette in
a reduced role for the next season.
The two-part finale also spends a fair amount
of time with Gurgs and her career ambitions.
Despondent over failing the Bailiff supervisors
exam, she attends Dan's going away party,
where her facility with remembering names
and faces impresses a representative from
Scotland Yard. Gurgs is invited
to a training program in London,
but after coming to Abby's aid as
a character witness in her trial,
the possibility of her moving overseas is dropped
and never mentioned again. Did Gurgs really give
up the opportunity of a lifetime to help out Abby,
or will her London adventures be seen in Season 2?
NBC renewed the series for a
second season in February 2023,
just a few weeks after its surprisingly
strong premiere. In a March interview
with "Collider," Melissa Rauch confirmed that
the writers' room had recently convened for
Season 2 and were working on the next batch of
scripts. No premiere date has been set just yet,
but the expectation was that "Night Court" would
return for a full season sometime in Fall 2023.
The WGA strike, however, may have changed
those plans. In May 2023, the Writers Guild
of America called a general strike over the
lack of compensation for television writers,
bringing most film and television production
to a halt. While some shows are continuing
to film during the strike without the input
of their writers, many others have chosen to
shutter production until the strike is resolved,
including "Night Court." Depending on how long the
strike lasts and how far into production
Season 2 was when the strike was called,
the show may not premiere until later
in the Fall, or perhaps Winter of 2024.
Melissa Rauch, who is a producer on the show
along with her husband Winston, is expected to
return for the second season, along with India
de Beaufort, Kapil Talwalkar, and Lacretta.
Larroquette, who was also credited as a producer
on the pilot episode, is a little more in doubt.
"Rand, Dan is leaving, but it's because
I helped him, gave his life new meaning,
et cetera, et cetera."
After the finale aired, Marsha Warfield confirmed
to "TVLine" that she will be returning as Roz for
at least one episode of Season 2, so it stands
to reason that we will see Dan at the same time,
though it's possible that Larroquette
may not return as a regular cast member.
There's one major character from the
original series that we're waiting
to see. Richard Moll's goofball bailiff Bull
Shannon was one of the show's breakout stars,
a kooky simpleton with a heart of gold. In the
two-parter that was planned as the original
series finale, Bull is convinced that a pair
of little old men seen around the courthouse
were in fact space aliens stalking him
for nefarious purposes. In the end,
his suspicions are confirmed. The little old men
really are aliens from the planet Jupiter and have
come to recruit Bull to grab all the things on
the planet that the aliens are too short to reach.
Bull accepts his destiny and disappears
from Harry's office in a flash of light.
30 years later, Bull is apparently still on
his interplanetary adventure. No mention of
the character was made in the revival season, and
Moll himself has long been hostile to the idea of
returning to the show. In 2013, when cornered
by a TMZ paparazzo in an L.A. parking garage,
he flatly stated that if any "Night Court"
reunion or reboot were to happen, he would,
quote, "run in the other direction."
Still, a lot can happen in a decade's time,
and it's not unheard of for actors to be
lured back to beloved roles. Could Bull
pop up in Season 2 of the "Night Court" revival?
The answer, so to speak, is written in the stars.